thank you very much Jason
to everybody for coming here
at swiping zones there's quite a lot of
things I want to say and I don't want to
miss anybody off but this this launch
event celebrates the official opening of
open doors project here at the former
King's Head pub in Rochford been so
delighted to have you here open doors is
a pilot scheme as Jessa's already said
from MHC LG it delivered by the
meanwhile foundation in partnership with
me my own space to CIC and that's been
looking to match landlords with empty
properties together with community
groups so we can find space and groups
who want to test their community
operating ideas and and bring positive
social change to to their town centres
and Watchmen Simon lucky it's being one
of only just five locations as part of
this ippolit or convening crowd and this
project brings new life in this historic
building under the town square and we're
hoping that will attract residents and
visitors our interruption and the
stimulating future confidence and
investment in our town